this is tim ferriss and welcome to the
tim ferriss show what you are about to
hear is part two of a two-part
conversation with Alex Bloomberg best
known for his work with this american
life as co-host of Planet Money and also
co-founder of gimlet media which has
produced to blockbuster podcasts at the
time of this particular episode namely
startup and reply all he is a true
master of storytelling crafting
narrative radio interviewing and much
more if you didn't catch the first part
you might want to do that before
venturing in but you can certainly
listen to this independently this second
part is an excerpt from a master class
that he taught on creativelive com I
think costs about ninety nine dollars
and it is phenomenal specifically in
this portion we are going to look at the
art of the interview and how to craft
and find the perfect question so I hope
you enjoy it and with that further ado
please enjoy part two of the tim ferriss
show with alex bloomberg at this
altitude I can run flat have for a half
mile before my hands start shaking and I
also personal question now it is soon
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton we're going to
be talking about in this segment is the
art of the interview and what I'm going
to be covering today what I'm going to
be covering this in this section is
first of all like sort of the most basic
question which is what what are you
going for when you're interviewing
somebody what are you trying to get out
of it what is the thing that you want to
what is a what does a good interview
look like right what does it feel like
when it's happening and as part of that
I'm going to go through what to ask how
do you come up with the questions to ask
and and I mean you're talking a little
bit about the power of the right
question and then I'm also going to be
talking about nuts and bolts so that's
coming up so what are you going for so
the first thing that you're that you're
going for is what we what we talked
about in the last section which is
authentic moments of you know sort of
authentic moments of authentic emotion
authentic sort of realization authentic
moments of humor something that feels
like a real emotion like those those are
golden moments in an interview and
that's sort of that's one of the things
that you're absolutely want to go for
and we talked a little bit about that
before and I'm going to talk about that
a little bit later but the thing that I
want to focus on now is the other thing
that we're talking about is um stories
and this and I am I have a avid sort of
a very specific meaning when I when I
say what what an actual story is but I'm
gonna but I think the first thing to do
is to is to sorry stories I think the
first thing to do is to play you a
little bit of what I'm talking about
what I'm talking about a story so I'm
going to play you a little piece of tape
so this is a story we got in this
american life a while ago and the setup
is that it's this actor Tate Donovan and
Tate Donovan is it was a sort of a
character actor he'd been you know sort
of on a couple of different shows
beating it
very much and then he had a like a stint
on friends and all the sudden he was
trying to get recognized and it was
really exciting for him to be recognized
because he finally got to be the
celebrity that he always wished that he
could be the celebrity that he would
have wanted to meet before he was famous
so when he got recognized and so one and
this story happens when one night he was
out at this Broadway show and a lot of
people were coming up to him being like
hey I saw you and he was able to like
talk to people and be very magnanimous
and say thank you so much it really
means a lot and he was like posing for
pictures for people and it was at the
show it was happening over and over and
over again I was I was I was exactly how
I wanted to be I was doing it I was
doing great and then the kid with the
camera came along
this nervous kid he must been 16 years
old he's in a rented tuxedo unbelievably
like shy and awkward and he's got acne
and he's got a camera in his hand and
underneath the marquee is his date who
is it literally like a prom dress and
she's got a corsage and she's really you
know nervous and sort of clutching her
hands and he sort of comes up to me sort
of mumbles you know something like you
know something about a picture and I'm
like I just feel for him so I'm like oh
absolutely my gosh sure no problem like
god you poor thing and and I go up to
his his girlfriend I wrap my arms around
her and I'm like hey where you from
fantastic going to see the play it's
great and the guy is sort of not taking
the photograph very quickly he's just
sort of staring at me and he's got his
camera his hands and it's down by his
like chin you know and and she's very
stiff and awkward and you know I don't
know what to do so I just leaned across
and I I kiss her on the cheek and I'm
like all right come on take the picture
hurry up you guys want to find out what
happens next that's a story when you
want to but so what that is the power of
a good narrative so when I talk about
I'm talking about like those two basic
things you're going for a motion and
narrative we as humans are hard-wired I
believe to listen to narrative and it's
a very simple sort of the mechanics of
narrative are very simple there's like a
sequence of actions and there's sort of
rising action and it's culminating in
something and you were in the middle of
that sequence of actions and you're
about to get to the culmination and I
stopped it and it's frustrating and you
really want to know what happens next
and you would never if you were
listening to this have turned off that
podcast or that radio story at that
moment and that is a good story and
that's why you want to operate in
stories that's why you when you're
interviewing people you want to get
their stories out of them and you want
to get them talking in stories because
stories are what we want to hear and so
when you're working in an audio format
you need to operate in stories the other
thing we want to hear as we heard before
is emotion so those are the two things
you're going for in a good interview so
moving on actually you want to hear what
happens next sorry all right i'll rewind
it again and then we'll have a play out
you know i don't know what to do so I
just leaned across and I kiss her on the
cheek and I'm like all right come on
Victor Victor hurry up and and finally
he sort of like snaps it and I'm like
okay it's really wonderful to meet you
and he just like stammered Dover to me
and was like um could you take a picture
of us oh and the whole time he just
wanted me to take a picture of him and
his girlfriend underneath the awning of
the play he didn't want to picture me he
had no idea who I was Oh God got a
little emotion in there too yeah so that
is what I'm talking about when destroy
so there is very simply we're gonna be
talking a lot more about what story is
in the next session but but very very
simply it is that it is a sequence of
actions that culminates in something
comes some sort of Revelation some sort
of punchlines some sort of joke some
sort of like realization and more to the
point it's something that you don't want
to turn off that you don't want to stop
listening to and so when so that is the
thing that's in your mind when you're
going out and doing an interview with
anybody you want to ask questions of the
interview subject that are going to
either elicit an honest emotional
reaction or there are going to elicit
them telling you a story so and there's
a lot of things that you can ask that
that well so let's let's talk about that
so so what to ask right so first if
you're trying to ask questions that go
that well you know alyssa is story first
of all you don't want to ask ever really
yes or no questions I mean you got to
get some facts out of the way but you
don't want to ask a yes or no question
because that is not that's the end of a
story right and so you how you phrase
the questions is very
important you want to sort of asked
questions I often sort of say tell me
about the time when write something you
know you were just like you want them to
tell you you use words like tell me so
they are automatically started to talk
to you in story language tell me about
the time tell me about the day when you
blah blah blah tell me about the moment
when you realized that this was what was
going to happen tell me about them the
time in your life when you were going
through this thing another question that
works really well tell me the story of
just ask them straight up all right you
know tell me the story of this how did
this happen tell me the story you know
sometimes that works another thing that
you when you you that you when you're on
the right track you know when you're on
the right track is when people are
actually sort of like talking to you in
dialogue if somebody is saying well
first I said and then she said and then
I said that's really that you know
you're on the right track here so often
i will tell people you know describe the
conversation where blah blah blah and
because if you get people sort of
telling you like he said then she said
then he said that she said that's great
you know you're on the right track that
somebody is telling you a story right
then because they're quoting dialogue to
you again tell me about the often what
you're going for is a moment of
realization so a story has to culminate
in something often this often the thing
that's culminating in is a moment of
realization so you want to say tell me
about the day that you realize whatever
it is that we're talking about here
another thing that really works well is
if people can sort of talk through a
process of you know there's there's
often steps that led from one situation
to the other situation what were the
steps that got you from one thing to
another what were the steps that got you
from you know your career and they offer
army to to your career as a celebrity
florist or whatever right so anybody
here have that career trajectory by the
way so so you want to ask that like sort
of what were the steps if you can get
people breaking it down into steps and
often each step is its own story so
often
step one will be well I was at you know
I was I was I was that I was no I have
my career in the army and this one thing
happened when I was you know in the Army
this day happened that I wanted that
made me want to change and so they'll
tell you that and that's a story each
step can be its own story but that
sequence of steps is also a story so
these are all sort of questions that
will that will elicit stories you want
to have people back up you want to do
all that stuff all right so that's one
whole set of questions and often when
you're doing so that's a whole set of
questions the other set of questions so
what do you ask if there's a whole other
set of questions that are built around
eliciting sort of honest reflection and
emotion so that's the other stock and
crate that's the other thing that you're
going for right pretty simple two things
so what do you so what do you ask when
when you're trying to get people to tell
you you know tell you how they feel one
question is how that make you feel like
it's pretty straightforward there's a
there's a app and joke that like doing a
good interview for for audio and and and
having a good sort of therapy session
look very similar because what you are
trying to do is get people to articulate
their emotions in words all you have an
audio are words that's all you have you
have people's words and so if they're
feeling something it's like if something
happens and you're not shooting at it
didn't happen if they're feeling
something and they don't articulate it
it also didn't happen so you need them
to articulate the way they're feeling
and so a lot of what you're doing is
you're in the audio you're in the
interview and you're like I noticed
feeling and your voice or in your manner
and I want you to articulate that
feeling and so so that's one thing and
so that's like how did that make you
feel is a big is it is a big one often
you also want to encourage that kind of
reflection some people just aren't very
naturally reflective but they've gone
through something sort of momentous and
you want them sort of like getting that
getting the the emotion in there so one
good trick I've I've known is sort of
like if the old New
could see the new you what would the old
you say because often you're going
you're you know you're interviewing
about something that has happened to
them they've gone through some sort of
transition and you want the you want
that moment you you want them to be able
to articulate what that transition meant
to them and these are all tricks we're
going to use by the way on one of our
audience members and coming up so we're
going to do a live interview coming up
in another section so so these are also
take notes because we're going to have
to employ this and you know use this in
action so a lot of what emotion is
around is around internal conflict so a
lot of and this is one of the things
that i love about audio which audio can
do uniquely well is that it can give
voice to interior sort of interior drama
if there's you know on television you
can sort of see people looking pensively
or you can sort of like you can sort of
you can get across an internal life but
stuff has to happen on you know on tape
you know it has to be happening and with
audio that you can you can give people
if you can get people to give voice to
these to the internal conflict it has
the power of any kind of real drama so
so what I often say to people is like
I'll often say like so complic you're
going for conflict but it can be
conflict within a person it can be a
person feeling conflicted about
something and so a big question that I
use a lot which is sort of like just if
you had to describe the debate in your
head over this moment over this act that
you took what was one side saying what
was the other side saying you know and
it's just getting people to sort of like
voice this this the feeling that they're
having and often our feelings or
contradictory right until you want that
and that's great if people have a
conflicted feeling when you're
interviewing them that's a wonderful
thing too that's what you want because
that's the way of breaking out of what
you were talking about and which is the
canned thing part of what being canned
is is just sort of just having like a
you know sort of like a very very
straightforward feeling about it that
you don't necessarily believe but you
can't shake people out of and so
what you want is to sort of like get at
like you know what what was the conflict
was there ever a point where you didn't
feel so confident confident about this
was there ever a point where you like
felt different like you know sort of
like you know and sort of and sometimes
it can be just as simple as sort of like
you seem very confident right now was
that always the case you know and if
they say no then just zero hit have had
like 0 and on the weakness the emotion
right like that's what you're that's
where your job is right another another
question that I would often happens in
an interview i bet you this will this
will happen to you as you're doing your
interviews somebody will say something
and it feels like very important to them
like you've said something that you know
is meaningful uh you know and I'd like
you know you're talking to like a you
know a real hard worker and they'll be
like well you know and then the boss
gave us like you know extra hours and
they say it like and you're like wow the
boss gave you extra out you're saying it
like it's important I have no idea what
it means but it means something to you
there's a motion in the voice right like
what does that mean and so and often you
and I would always love this thing I
would know that there was something that
they were getting at but they weren't
articulating it to me and and then and
then I were use this question use this
question all the time and it's a really
great question and it's super
straightforward it's just sort of like
what do you make of that and so I
actually it all the time now because
like I'm often I just need them to tell
me the reason that there's a motion and
the thing that they just said so what do
you make of that is really a really
really important question the other
thing that I think one of the most
important things that we which is you
know sort of like part of the whatever
you make what do you make of that
question again you sort of asked what do
you make of that and then you're it's
sort of a dumb question you sort of feel
like an idiot for asking it's like sort
of like basic and weird and like it's
not a question that you actually ask
that often in normal conversation and so
and this gets to the point of sort of
like are you having a real conversation
are you having a stage
conversation sort of to elicit certain
things and you're doing a little bit of
both right and the one of you make of
that is very much like a staged sort of
therapy kind of conversation you know
what I mean and so but really important
is to then shut up I can't get across
enough the importance of shutting up and
like early on in my career I would come
back and I would just be talking so much
and people would start to be telling me
interesting things and I would be
talking over them and and it was all
because I was nervous and I was worried
about like sort of making them feel
uncomfortable and you sort of want them
to feel uncomfortable a little bit not
totally uncomfortable so that they're
not going to be like talking to you you
want them to feel you want them to feel
safe but you want them to feel like
they're saying something real which is
often uncomfortable so you want it to be
safe you're not judgmental at all you
never want to be judgmental but you want
to be asking real questions you want
them to be thinking real really about
them so another another just sort of you
know good good question that sort of
gets at this is that is the why is this
story meaningful to you coming up the
power of the right question and how to
craft it to get honest responses deep
responses including plenty of clips but
first a short word from our sponsors the
tim ferriss show is brought to you by on
it i have used on it products for years
if you look in my kitchen in my garage
you will find alpha brain chewable
melatonin for resetting my clock when
I'm traveling kettlebells battle ropes
maces steel clubs sounds like a torture
chamber and it kind of is it's a torture
chamber for self-improvement and you can
see all of my favorite gear at on it
calm forward slash Tim that's ONN I
t.com forward slash Tim and you can also
get a discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
bran check it all out on it calm forward
slash Tim
the tempura shows also brought to you by
99designs 99designs is your
one-stop-shop for anything graphic
design related you need a logo you need
a website you need a business card or
anything else you get an original design
from designers around the world who
submit drafts for you to review you are
happy or you get your money back and I
have used 99 designs for book cover
ideas for the 4-hour body which went to
number one new york times for banner ads
and you can check out some of my actual
competitions at 99 designs.com forward
slash tim you can also get a free 99
dollar upgrade if you want to give it a
shot that's 99 designs.com forward slash
tim and now back to the show so just to
sort of get across like sort of like the
the power of like sort of what this with
this question what you know asking the
right question I want to I want to play
a couple clips of tape here and this
first one is like a story that we did on
so this is this first sort of like
illustration of the power of asking the
right question and getting people that
you know to reflect honestly it's a
weird story it was a sort of this really
conceptual story that we did at this
american life a while ago and it was
this reporter named Davey rothbard and I
was the producer on the story so I went
went out with him and asked all these
questions and the conceptual story was
this Davey lived on this block in
Chicago it was sort of like a sort of a
black in transition there was like some
sort of yep he's moving in but it had
been sort of like a poor it was there's
some gang problems there and it was like
sort of an it was a neighborhood in
transition and he lived on this block
and there was all these problems that
with the neighborhood was having with
each other like different neighbors were
like having different conflicts with
each other and there was like a neighbor
and its building who's complaining about
his loud music and was constantly
banging on the floor and then there was
another neighbor that had thought that
like that somebody else stole her dog
and then there was like you know so
there's all these things and and the
idea was that Davey was the idea of the
story was that Davey was going to sort
of like collect all these problems in
every all the people in his neighborhood
and then take
problems that were happening in this
neighborhood to an expert on neighbor
relations call it 544 round Phillips I
set up the wrong piece of tape I'm a dad
sorry ah crap oh there it is right there
in my notes I missed it myself but
everybody's day this is another because
this will be very quickly sorry free
keep all that in your mind for a second
and there's two there's two stories I my
plate I'm gonna play the first one out
in order so so so this is a different
story this is one that I did in the
housing crisis this is sore from 2008
and it was one of the more famous
stories that it was called the giant
pool of money and it was about the
housing meltdown basically and back in
two thousand eight there's other stuff
happening with subprime mortgages and a
lot of the coverage was about our um who
you know like who's at fault is it like
we're dead beats taking out loans that
they knew they couldn't pay back and
then like ripping off the banks or were
like poor people being victimized by
evil banks that were now foreclosing on
their homes and that was the sort of the
narrative and neither narrative really
ever made sense to me and I kept them
thinking like there's like there's
something else going on here something
bigger and more systemic that's going on
then just like either people ripping off
banks or banks rupee off people and I
wanted to get at the heart of it and
there was like this question so we found
this guy who is you know who was going
through foreclosure and he was telling
the story of how of how he got this loan
this enormous loan and in the middle of
this clip you'll hear the question that
I'm talking about the question that I
felt like turned the whole thing and
sort of set up the entire show as a
matter of fact but sort of got him
talking in a very different way so this
guy's name is Clarence he'd taken out a
huge loan almost over half a million
dollars at the time of that loan he had
three not very reliable part-time jobs
he was making about forty five thousand
dollars a year and on the loan that he
took out they didn't ask him anything
about his income call it 544 round
figures do you basically borrowed five
hundred forty thousand dollars from the
bank and they didn't check your income
it's a no income verification loan they
don't call me up and say you know how
much money they don't do that I mean
it's it's almost like you pass a guy in
the street and say let me five hundred
forty thousand dollars he said well what
do you do hack a job okay I mean it it
seems as if it's that casual even though
there are a lot of papers that get
filled out and stuff flies all over with
the faxes and the emails and all like
that essentially that's the process
would would you have loaned you the
money I wouldn't have loaned me the
money and nobody that I know would have
loaned me the money I mean I know guys
who are criminals that wouldn't lend me
that money and they break your kneecaps
oh yeah happy have a flashback did it
I'm serious hey five hundred and forty
thousand dollars a person with bad
credit so I love that piece of tape
because like it was the first time in my
experience that anybody first of all
clearance is at the center of the
problem and i'm asking him how he feels
about like that question got enabled me
to sidestep the whole whose fault is it
in a way and it just got to a very
honest reaction from him which was sort
of like like the what there's all sorts
of other ways to phrase that question
did you deserve that money should the
bank of giving you that money blah blah
blah and all that would have led to a
defensive answer it would have led to
not the right answer but all this but
then when I was like in the middle of it
I remember thinking like oh that's the
question and when I asked them would you
have loaned you the money it forced him
to be honest there was no way to sort of
not be honest about answering that
question and and it got like a really
wonderful sort of honest response that
then set up the entire hour basically so
like why were other people lending money
to people that those people themselves
would not have lent to them right so
like what what was going on there and
that it's sort of like that Pat that
that question set up the entire thing
alright so I teased this next piece of
paper mistakenly so going back with cast
your minds back to
when I set this up before so anyway
Davey Rothbard taking getting all these
questions from his from his all these
questions from his the people in his
neighborhood and he's all the problems
and he's running it by an expert in
neighbor relations
here's the bridge mr. Rogers yes mr.
Rogers whose since passed away Fred
Rogers so I guess said it was a weird
conceptual story we're taking problem
these problems from this leg sort of
like rough block of west augusta in
chicago and then bringing them in front
of mr. rogers and asking him to sort of
pronounce judgment what these neighbors
should do it was weird there's a
backstory that I won't even get into but
uh but it was minus all to sort of talk
about because there was this was one of
those moments were like the question
really brought us to a different place
one of the one of the things that like
so there was this so one of the problems
that Davy had identified when I played
one more piece of tape and then we'll
get to the tape with a question so one
of the problems that Davy had identified
in his neighborhood was that there was
this fear right that was one of the big
things so there was like Peter the
people banging on the floor you know the
music playing too loud there was a kid
there's a guy who's neighbor thought
he'd stole her dog and then but mainly
there was like a lot of fear there was
like the fear of like the yuppies moving
into into the neighborhood were afraid
of the kids who are in the gangs and and
so Davy talked about that you don't hear
davion and he'll hear a kid name of the
mouth who's interviewing who exactly are
you afraid of my desk they'll answer the
same way the gangbangers the kids in
baggy jeans and basketball jerseys who
cruised the neighborhood with their
stereos bumping the gangbangers they
said those are the bad neighbors maybe
even 10 you guess it's no surprise the
mouth had his own idea about who the bad
neighbors are the ones who fear and
distrust him never had a neighbor in the
neighborhood that he didn't agree with
what we did so much so he'd he'd stand
in his hospital a video camera and
record what we were doing try to bring
it to the beat meetings you know he used
to follow us around with cameras
literally follow us around the
neighborhood of camera you know and say
I'm gonna call the cops are using you
know what for what we ain't bothering
you you know that's what I think the
worst neighbor is you know yeah they
come in here fearing on saying that you
know maybe thinking that we're gonna do
this and do that but we'll talk to you
you know what I'm saying bro oween you
know we ain't animals brought when
normal people like you alright so that's
the mouth and his friends we're sitting
on the street drinking Heinekens and um
so we bring that mr. redress and so all
that so mr. Rogers is a wonderful lovely
man meeting him was a thrill he's got
the strange sort of power when you meet
him it was crazy he would like he when
we went to meet him his assistant said
we were trying to set up the interview
and his assistant was like well Fred
likes to be with nearby a piano so we
had to meet him in his studio so you
could play the piano every once in a
while he literally he had the bag of
puppets and he would bring them out
sometimes to make a point and start
talking in the puppet voices while we
were talking and yet somehow it was like
moving and real I don't know he was an
amazing person amazing uh but he was
getting he was giving us some a little
bit of canned answers like when we were
answering sort of what should this
neighbor do his answer was always sorta
sort of the same like you know well I
hope I would be brave enough to go and
talk to them I would hope that I would
be brave enough to visit it's so easy to
condemn when we don't know and if I
would visit you and find out that you
are a reasonable person I could tell you
about my sensitivities and see if it
would make any difference to you it's
funny a lot of the things like you know
you said if you were in Daviess
neighbors situation you said that you
hoped you would have enough courage to
go down and visit and a lot of what you
were finding when you were talking to
people had to do with that same sort of
notion and I'm wondering like what what
is it that we're afraid of do you think
perhaps we think that we won't find
another human being inside that person
perhaps we think that oh there there
maybe are people in this world who I
can't ever communicate with and so i'll
just give up before i try and how sad it
is to think that that we would give up
on any other creature who's just like us
so um what do you thoughts about that i
thought i'd love to hear what you like
what was going on in your mind anybody
respond yeah that was mr. Rogers like
that was so powerful yeah and you could
hear the flutter in his voice which was
his motion you know rippling through his
vocal cords right and it was amazing and
it was such an interesting contrast to
think of mr. Rogers and like it sounded
like the Buddha exactly wonderful great
buddha like in prison yeah yeah but but
it was like but that was one of the that
was the that was the most honest moment
in that in that interview you know and
it and it came out of like there was
this question that was sort of hovering
over it and he was giving slightly he
said did i hear this and I wonder if you
do too like in the beginning he sounded
more canned and then after I asked the
question right you can hear it all of a
sudden he's actually pausing and he's
actually thinking he's actually trying
to figure out what is the emotion and
he's trying to voice that emotion and
all the sudden becomes real and it
becomes authentic and you connect to
that moment yeah yeah yeah I think the
fact that he is mr. Rogers carries
particular weight yeah we're used to
hearing him and we're used to hearing
him do those canned simple solutions
oriented just do this and I'll be great
for me that that moment of real darkness
when he identifies the greatest fear is
I will never be able to communicate with
you right yeah and as a listener I can
extrapolate that out to the neighborhood
I can see how that person would think
bad about that person and it just took
me somewhere so hopeless yeah we needs
usually someone
is all about so that juxtaposition of
what I expect to hear from him and I
want to hear from him is incredibly
power right and I think but I think
that's a really great point because I
think that's what you're trying to do
with it that's what this that's what a
honest moment will do it with anybody
whether it's mr. Rogers or not if you
hear people talking and the way we all
talk we're all sort of like you know
going through putting up fronts and
lying to ourselves in various ways but
as we go through our day and you know
nobody's going to notice that I actually
screwed up the order of my table for
example but uh but you know that that
that when they break out when you break
out of it even if you're not mr. Rogers
that it that's what comes through that's
the thing that comes through yeah good I
was just going to say that he really
took something that may be many of us
could not relate to like living in a
project and when he answered that when
you asked that question about fear it
made it so personal yeah that I
immediately was thinking to myself what
am I fearing and he took this kind of
out there thing and brought it deep yeah
and and so because it was personal then
it was more important to me like you
said earlier in the day right yeah and
then and I engaged with that immediately
right and he was identifying something I
mean again that it's also sort of like
identifying putting words to to a
feeling that we have that is sort of
undiagnosed or unsorted explained that
is sort of a definition of profundity a
little bit you know what I mean when you
can actually give voice to but you know
put that in words the feeling that we
share and that's what he did with I like
oh that is our fear that is the fear
right where we're afraid that people
that we are going to encounter somebody
who is who we can't connect with as
humans yeah yeah I think it's also
incredible because he uses his own
language he doesn't break out of being
mr. Rogers you know he actually manages
to remain himself and still go to this
really different place for him and
that's how that's how at least I could
tell it was really honest was that he
would like you also get to know mr.
Rogers honestly yeah Anna and
language yeah yeah exactly and you can
see why like mr. Rogers of all people
would find that a especially horrifying
thing you know like you think yeah that
like well the people that there are bad
people in the world is just like such a
yeah it's like it's more poignant for
Miss Rogers than any of us yeah Morgan
yeah just going off of that at the end
here's is the word creature instead of
like another human like we're all just
yeah these BS like connect with another
be you know it's not within our organism
yeah yeah I'm from the Saturn Jennifer
says of all people coming from someone
who so genuinely and innocently sees the
beauty in people acknowledging that core
fear is really powerful and Claudia says
you can feel how carefully he's thinking
about the question and that makes it
very authentic absolutely absolutely you
can hear it for the first time he didn't
never ready answer yeah you know and
that was that's important too and so um
and again like I don't think that moment
would have happened you know I often
feel like there's like in every
interview we're in a lot of interviews
there's like this there's a question
that sort of hanging over the interview
that if like you can just figure out
what that question is what's the one
that's going to like sort of like what
are we talking around and can you can
you can you figure out what that isn't
and sort of presented to people they get
it breaks through often like you again
the therapy language you have a
breakthrough a little bit you know and
that's what you're sort of going for
Jeff I'm wondering if both of those
clips ended up in the final cut and
whether or not you like including that
transition when when you get the right
question and that person changing from
their canned response to to the more
personal honest one oh yeah yeah
absolutely no because you have to yet
know those are both pulled from the
actual final version so like that's what
the music was there and everything about
that was the that was i just downloaded
the clip off of itunes and put it now
that was like that yeah but but wait is
that was that your answer was it well i
was wondering if you had gotten the
second answer first if that would have
satisfied you or if you like capturing
that moment when you kind of owe someone
it's interesting like did you need the
drama of him giving a can't answer first
and then like breakthrough there's
something nice I mean that
there is something about that where you
where it's nice to like that it was the
same thing that happened the dave ramsey
thing where where somebody is not being
totally honest and then there's a
question that sort of confronts them I
don't know that's a good question i
think i think it it helps i think
because it also sort of tells a story
it's like it's like a court I feel like
it's like a cord resolving in music when
you're just like waiting for the cord
and then you finally the power cord
comes me like yeah that's how it feels a
little bit you know where we're like
we're like somebody is sort of like
wrestling with that they're not being
honest and I've being honest an end date
there's a question that breaks them out
of it and then they acknowledge it
there's there's a nice feeling to that
as well but I think it could work either
way like i will have we often will use
the answer without using the question
and it often is just as powerful you
know you don't need to include the whole
thing you know it just how it works yeah
i mean a couple of questions come in and
I think tie in nicely to these clips
that we do have heard so I'd love to get
your opinion on this so in that in that
clip you were talking about getting that
location that street in Chicago so this
ties into a question that Brayden had
who says when you're reporting on a town
or a location or with mr. Rogers a
neighborhood do you have a methodology
for getting to know that town or that
place god that's that is tricky to have
a methodology no i don't i think and i
think but my methodology is try to find
somebody who knows it better than me is
to sort of like go and find the ID the
person who is ID the person who is the
exemplar of whatever it is like if
there's somebody if it's a if it's a
town and there's like somebody who's in
that town who sort of represents sort of
the mainstream view of the town and then
identify the outsider the goth kid or
whatever who can sort of like you have a
more anthropological view of the town
and if you get both of those people
generally you're sort of circling around
some sort of authentic picture of it but
you're always like that's the biggest
difficulty of being a journalist is sort
of like parachuting in someplace trying
to pretend trying to get as much as you
can about the place but you never know
you never know as much as you wish you
knew and you never have time to figure
it all out you know entirely generally
what I'm reporting on a topic when I
find that I have that I'm getting the
same answers from enough people like
when I feel like okay well I've done
enough reporting
that I'm getting similar answers yeah
coming up a sample from my episode with
Arnold Schwarzenegger the one and only
coming soon but i'm going to give you a
preview the first just a short word from
our sponsors the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by on it i have used on
it products for years if you look in my
kitchen in my garage you will find alpha
brain chewable melatonin for resetting
my clock when i'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel clubs sounds
like a torture chamber and it kind of is
it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it calm forward
slash Tim that's ONN I t-dot-com forward
slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
brand check it all out on it calm
forward slash Tim the Tim Ferriss shows
also brought to you by 99designs
99designs is your one-stop shop for
anything graphic design related you need
a logo you need a website you need a
business card or anything else you get
an original design from designers around
the world who submit drafts for you to
review you are happy or you get your
money back and I have used 99 designs
for book cover ideas for the 4-hour body
which went to number one new york times
for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual competitions at 99
designs.com forward slash tim you can
also get a free 99 dollar upgrade if you
want to give it a shot that's 99
designs.com forward slash tim
and now back to the show those days
there was no money in bodybuilding and
so when we didn't have enough money we
literally had to go to work and so Frank
and I since Franco's talent was to be a
bricklayer and it's very skilled prick
layer and learned that in Italy and in
Germany being were able to go and start
thinking about the idea of putting an ad
in the LA Times creating a company and
calling it European bricklayers and
masonry experts marble experts building
chimneys and fireplaces the European
style and this was also a time where
everything that was européenne was huge
in America so we benefited from that you
know Swedish massages and everything had
to be kind of a foreign name or a
Japanese this and they said so europe
and japan and all this better places you
never used the names were used because
for some reason to the other people just
thought that was better and so we use
that in the ad and we put the ad in the
paper and literally a week later we had
the big earthquake in Los Angeles I mean
the chimneys fell off the the apartment
houses and orders up and had cracked
walls and orders and so Frank and I we
as America one of the friend of ours
wife who was very smart and she worked
in a supermarket she did answering the
phones and calling people back and
laura's just to make sure that I English
doesn't get all screwed up with the
talking over the phone and orders and
and and so she gave us in the addresses
and then we got to do the estimates and
I was kind of like set up to be the math
genius and it figures out the square
footage and that Franco would play the
bad guy and I played a good guy and so
we will go to someone's house and then
someone would say well look at my patio
is all cracked can you guys put the new
patio in here and I would say yes and
then we run around with the tape measure
but there would be a dead measure with
centimeters no one in those days
they'd all figure out anything with
centimeters and we will be measuring up
and SI vertices you know four meters and
eighty two centimeters and they had no
idea we talking about and this is so
much and then we will be writing up
formulas and the dollars in the mounts
and square centimeters and square meters
and all this stuff and then I will go to
the guy and I said well I said it's five
thousand dollars and the guy will be in
a state of shock and you say so that's
five thousand dollars i said this is
outrageous I said they didn't think that
this is a well what did you expect that
the basis I thought maybe it's like two
three thousand dollars is about 5,000 it
says a cinema stood let me talk to my
guys is because he's really the masonry
expert I said but I can beat him down
for a little bit here let me soften the
meat and then said we'll go all with the
Frank and we were still arguing in
German you know this is any shina writer
constantly so far field analysis
templates need me I'm here in America
and this will be coming on Avery
screaming back and me in Italian and
some stuff and then ever be then always
ND calm down and never go to the guys if
who okay here is I said I could get him
as low as three thousand eight hundred
dollars I see can you go with that and
he says thank you very much he says you
know I i really think that you're a
great man blah blah blah notice FSA okay
I say give us half down right now we go
right away and get the cement and get
the breaks and everything that we need
for here and we can start working i said
on monday and the guy was ecstatic gave
us the money we immediately ran to the
bank cash to check it to make sure that
the money is in the bank account and
then when the album got the cement the
wheelbarrow and the older the stuff that
we needed and it went to brooke and so
we worked like that for two years i mean
very successfully as a metric ton and we
had the various different jobs will be
employed like 16 different body builders
all the laziest bastard said you can
never hire but never the because they
are interested in working out door in
getting a tan at the same time for the
bodybuilding competition
if you enjoyed this episode you are
going to love what I have coming all
sorts of crazy experiments incredible
guests and you can very easily not miss
any of it just subscribe on iTunes or
you can check out all of my guests as
well as my blog that has 122 million
readers per month at four hour workweek
calm all spelled out four hour workweek
calm that's where I Chronicle all of my
insane self-experimentation and I would
love to hear from you so please reach
out to me on twitter twitter com /t
Ferris TF er Riss or on facebook at
facebook.com/ forward slash Tim Paris
with two hours and two S's of course and
until next time thank you so much for
listening
you